many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism what is the
most important idea in stoicism this is
a perfectly natural question but it
doesn't have a good answer in part
because somebody's asking for what can't
really be provided now of course anybody
can pull an idea out of the air and say
this is the most important one but if
you read your stoic texts and you think
through how Stoics actually live you can
see that there isn't one single most
important idea
there's instead an entire framework of
ideas and if you try to oversimplify you
actually start to not only lose the
efficacy of the stoic approach but you
start to misunderstand it and get into a
number of quandary
and paradoxes before I introduce you to
a few of the candidates for the most
important idea and stoicism the things
that people often put forward as the one
central fundamental idea I want to talk
about this this notion that there should
in fact be one key insight one key
practice one kernel that everything else
would somehow grow out of and I used a
metaphor there of growth you know like a
seed stoicism doesn't work that way
philosophies in general don't work that
way and that's part of what's good about
them it's not just about having one idea
and then driving that thing into the
ground it's about putting multiple ideas
together which is a much more powerful
approach in part because reality out
there is a hell of a lot more
complicated than one idea can do justice
to especially when we're taking account
of the reality in here
of the human being and human nature some
of the big ideas that often get proposed
as the most important or the most
significant idea concept practice
what-have-you in stoicism are the
following one is what's called the
dichotomy of control some things are in
our control other things are not in our
control and we want to get that idea
straight that distinction so we can
apply it properly another is that virtue
is the only true good and correlative
lis vise is the only true evil another
idea is that we human beings are not
simply stuck with or the prey of our
thoughts desires emotions we can have
some measure of choice and control when
it comes to those a fourth key idea is
that the human being is fundamentally a
rational animal and that this involves
us within an entire social matrix of
other people with whom we have
relationships and roles and those
influence how our life goes another key
idea is that it's not events or persons
or whatever else is coming at us from
the outside that makes us suffer but
rather our own judgments and attitudes
about those events and persons yet
another idea that that is really at the
core stoicism is that the entire
universe including our you know
microcosm within is fundamentally
rational and that much of the problems
that we we encounter and suffer from
have to do from a bad fit between
ourselves and the rationality of the
whole and then a final idea that I think
often gets brought up very calm
Lexx idea by itself is that we ought to
be living in accordance with nature now
each of these gets put forth by some
people as being the one most important
idea of Stoicism each of these ideas
that I've introduced you to is a main
idea of stoic philosophy some of them
actually were not articulated as such
until fairly late like the dichotomy of
control
but that's a very important one and
instead of trying to say which of these
is the one that I have to concentrate on
you should think of it as a set of ideas
that connect up with each other and help
to inform each other sort of like a net
or a network if you like composed of a
bunch of knots or nodes in which that
composes the fabric of the whole and
that's what gives it its strength you
don't want to be the sort of person who
has one idea and that ignores all of the
rest because if you do that you're not
really getting that much even out of
that very idea and you won't be
connecting it with the other key ideas
of stoic philosophy so it's great if
you're asking this question but you
really want to reformulate it into what
are the most important ideas about
stoicism and then you want to follow it
up with where do I go to actually learn
about these if you found this answer
helpful for you then please share it
with others who might benefit from it
this work is entirely supported by
crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Saddler